i think we like the same look we like
that louie bronzy
see mistakes happen like past
relationships you kind of just
rub it off let it go and start all over
again start fresh
i'm darcy silva and i'm stacy silva and
today we're unfiltered from our home
honestly my makeup routine lasts about
15-20 minutes
tops and since quarantine i love the
darcy glow
i'm pretty much the same usually i like
to do the glam look as much as possible
but during quarantine
i keep it natural and dewy and fresh
there's never enough makeup we love
makeup that
snatched contour glam look
what i do first with my beauty routine i
like to keep
my skin feeling snatched and kind of
like
conditioned with like serum and stuff
it's kind of like a pre-prep
for the makeup so i think we pretty much
have the same routine what you're going
to pull out
oh i got my tools you got all right
let's see if we can do it
i got the face oil that's our one of our
secrets to a nice glow i kind of just
do it in an upward motion like dab
a little dab will do yeah got one of
those too you let it soak it in your
skin better
you gotta roll it in look at all that
the jaw
you see should we do that oh my gosh
i like this one better even the lips i
like them juicy
instant face lift oh if he doesn't like
that
one thing that actually is different
about me and darcy is that
um i was diagnosed with vitiligo you
know growing up it was difficult because
i would get teased for it and it's on my
face and you can kind of see
it's like in the shape of a triangle and
it goes into my eyebrow
you know forget about that i have
vitiligo but it's made me who i am it's
made me a stronger woman and i embrace
it now
i love to do this next it gives you
those baby doll eyes it's
a squirt each and it makes the white of
your eyes
you can do it
it makes the white of your eyes pop
just kind of a little trick on the trade
a little trick of the trade
we had an amazing childhood honestly we
traveled the world
since the age of three we lived in
london japan singapore
we went to school overseas the whole
international
thing is in our blood our family unit
has always been strong our dad's an
engineer
by trade so we've always had the
opportunity to move all over the world
and our mom
um was always with us as well we were
always the new kids in school we had to
move every like year or two years so
at least stacy and i had each other so
that's where our strength and our bond
really you know we stay close and always
have each other's back
and our older brother michael who has
since passed on from a rare form of
cancer
he's always with us in spirit and he
always had her back
yeah yeah it was the three of us that's
why we actually got
these tattoos when we first moved to l.a
we lived in l.a for eight years after a
divorce we actually got divorced on the
same day and
moved to la and stayed there eight years
and that's where we started house of
eleven in honor of michael yeah to
continue
his legacy in his honor because he was
so strong and that's where we feel like
we get a lot of our strength is
everything he kind of went through um we
won't ever give up because he didn't
give up
[Music]
we created vision boards after we had
our kids and
we're really inspired by many things in
the industry so we moved to l.a started
a production company eleventh
entertainment
thirty two yeah we produced our own tv
pilot called the twin life
we got into the movie business we
produced a couple films dabbled in music
too
[Music]
we've been around the world since the
age of three we you know
love to date internationally you like we
used to meet people from different
cultures we love that our ex-husbands
were european
and you know we just happened to do
things in tandem and we're
you know love to date europeans nothing
against american men we love them too
just the connection that you uh you have
somebody yeah yeah i'm on the contour
part i like to do the little glow so i
like to add a little
you know um elixir like a gold elixir
it kind of hides the imperfections
especially if you haven't gotten any
fillers or botox lately because i sure
need some
we're going to take a look back at some
of my 90 day fashion moments
first time meeting you you've got to
look your best
it's a long travel day you want to feel
fresh
when you get to your destination so you
know you definitely have to have a
special
scent you know you got to smell good
this one's beachy because we haven't
been to the don't get in my
for squirts of perfume i just i just do
it it depends
how long i've traveled you know
sometimes you got to spray you know the
deck with
hay you want to do like you know your
hair sometimes your legs
just because it's like gets hot sweaty
when you're running around or like
in a you know hot airport or on a plane
for a long time or in a car
so yeah i definitely like a lot of
squirts
a little bronzer don't kill nobody you
gotta have a little bronzer
that's definitely what keeps that glow
going and it
you know pops the cheeks so when you
smile big
when you meet you know someone you care
for
you gotta look pretty and you gotta pop
there you go yeah and then you highlight
it a little bit gotta give it a little
pop
oh my goodness oh that moment she
actually called me
um shortly after she's like oh my god
you'll never believe what happened
my brand new christian louboutin got
stuck in the escalator and
for me that was a definite red flag and
i literally was like oh my god i'm
either gonna like fall flat on my face
die or like
you know i just had to jump i'd jump out
of like both shoes
it actually broke their escalator i
still have those shoes i
don't wear them as much anymore i kind
of feel like i need to buy another pair
they're
totally trying to rid all the negative
energy from the past and sometimes
it might linger on in shoes clothes or
whatever else
i um i want to give something
with you home jesse's jacket's probably
somewhere in storage i don't even know
like i thought you shifted all that
no you didn't ask for anything like that
actually i left a lot of stuff there
that he was like
um that's where he was like still trying
to contact
i was like just donate it you know what
there it's somewhere i don't really know
where it is
it's like i don't want it in our house
so probably in some boxes somewhere that
we have some storage units so
eh can you be quiet yes i'm talking i'm
trying to
elaborate on what she asked me in the
world today you know television
and being on reality tv people love to
watch
you know people's stories and drama
sometimes i'm stronger now i just
don't ever want to feel like chipped
away and we get very vulnerable at time
i think people have a misconception that
i'm
desperate darcy but i'm not really
strong i'm a strong inspired
you know person individual and for my
daughters i want to be able to
be there for them and you know be strong
for them the torment i had gone through
very bad and i am strong i'm not gonna
let any man take me down
so i think um people might see me as
ultra sensitive that i cry all the time
no i have a heart just like everybody
else and i know what i deserve
so sometimes that hits me hard and at
least i can be open and honest about it
i'm okay with sharing that about my
makes you real and who you are and
i think for the most part people love
you and this is one of my other tricks
right here
it gives you that snatched look and then
you gotta bake it with the powder
yeah the little dab here
it opens up your eye and then you can
put it
underneath your eyebrow to give you that
arch there you blend it in there you go
i'll come rescue you if i have to why
before i'm good
see you in six weeks i think we both
kind of know the franchise together at
the same time
um you know stacy got to be you know
part of that journey
going to albania with florian which was
really cool that was a journey
that i'll never forget why do you think
i don't love you
because i feel like i'm not gonna have
free
yeah there was some things that happened
after that a little bit
uh at the hotel room that nobody knows
but
stacy knows and flooring we invited them
over
and someone was in an interesting giddy
mood because
you could say it's these yeah there was
a point at that later um
early that morning where uh actually
tom had popped the question to darcy and
it was just like
kind of out of left field and yeah after
all that caught her off guard and
it was it was like the next day he never
he never brought it up again
i never gave him a response because i
didn't trust him he was been drinking
too
he never talked about it the next day it
was just kind of like i think a drunken
moment or just
just didn't feel i don't know we were
all like what
are you being serious right now yeah it
was i didn't take him seriously i was
kind of like was he just trying to say
this to like make himself feel better
about what just happened earlier that
night so i was just like
if he's gonna do it at least get out of
me but he didn't he was sitting in a
chair
with you know some champagne or
something anything
well you know i know what i'm worth and
i know what i deserve so it was a
blessing in disguise that i was like
yeah i'm like nah i'm not desperate
darcy here so
don't make me feel like one
i think we like the same look we like
that chloe bronzy
see mistakes happen start all over like
past relationships you kind of just rub
it off
let it go and start all over again start
fresh
you know because when you really want
something that's meant to be
you just yeah here you see it bring it
out and wing it out
and you'll wing it good okay so this is
our
cold laser therapy treatment
suck it up baby when stacy and i go do
our cosmetic procedures we
really feel excited that we get to do it
together and we're petite we're
you know five two and you know weight
comes on easy at times so we have to
really be careful
and after the tummy tucks i feel so much
better you feel lighter
and yeah you know got new boobs they're
you know about the same size
doctor did it you know in tandem one
went first and then the others
so they always got a chuckle about that
all our doctors
so we don't want to look too different
because we are twins so we went to
different doctors it probably wouldn't
have made sense so it's always best to
go together
sometimes i think back and i'm like
should i have said that or shouldn't i
not have said that yeah how do i mess
everything up just
your mouth do you just you know why are
you being so rude
to your sister you know i've always kind
of spoke my mind and said how i was
feeling internally
honestly there's really nothing that i
wish i hadn't said on the show but
i kind of wish that i voiced my concern
more about the relationship with jesse
because i saw how toxic it was even
behind the scenes and off camera
there were so many moments when he came
to new york to
basically break up with her i felt it in
my gut i had a twin tuition
i told her please don't go yeah because
i feel like there's he's up to something
and she obvious yeah see yeah obviously
went with her heart i am in new york and
i am here to break up with darcy i felt
that tuesdays
but you know i had to own up to i had to
like you know tell them
you can't treat me like this anymore but
i think that's where the twin
tuition and the twin dynamic comes in is
um you know we feel each other's
pain and i kind of almost feel like we
almost know we're away
forewarn each other twin power ready
eyelashes and all for me the perception
of beauty
has evolved over the years i know for me
when i
evolved into who i am today beautiful i
feel like a goddess now
for me perception of beauty started
um at a young age i feel like it started
with the women in our family
and since then i just
i learned to love myself and i learned
to accept
my flaws and embrace them yeah i think
both of our journeys with beauty is
inspiring because
you know we did get teased as kids we
love ourselves it doesn't matter the
outside it's really the inside
because that exudes more than just you
know makeup
on your face and we are here to you know
hopefully
make people smile and know that no
matter how bad you're feeling or if
you're in a bad relationship you could
stay strong empowered and
never let anyone take your power away
that's right yeah
i like to do a little highlight here
cupid's bow mm-hmm
my little pops yeah a little dab will do
you a little dabble do you
i don't think georgie ever complained
with these juicy lips
one of the most beautiful thing about
stacy is that she has a
beautiful giving heart you know she
always is a giver
especially when it comes to her sons
they're amazing boys very super talented
and you know what it's all love there
yeah just like i have the two daughters
she has
two sons and i see her lighting up when
she's around
matteo and parker and the kids are
growing up together
beautifully and we're very blessed for
that i think
the kids really just make us shine
bright darcy is the most beautiful
you know what i might it might sound the
same but you know her heart
she really has a big heart she's a big
giver
and you know what i just i just love
that she's genuine and she's real
no other way to be yeah no other way to
be
that's right
you